[Music]
so after
i read the story i decided i'm going to
be eating more kimchi
oh is it that corona kimchi the
fermented
gut yes this is where we all pretend
like we like kimchi but we all actually
really don't
you don't like kids i love kimchi why do
you pretend you like it if you don't you
don't no i don't pretend
i'm saying all of you are cold i'm
saying i know
is this charade who knows what you guys
are doing i love kimchi
we even feed it to taiko i grew up on
all different types of kimchi i eat more
kimchi now than i ever did
same do you like stinky tofu like casey
claims he does
i've never tried it you think he's lying
i don't actually you can't fake liking i
don't actually i don't actually think
and i don't know we should have steve
eat it oh my god you might throw up
i hate it and durian dude it was [ __ ]
the same day the first time i smelled it
i was like
i don't smell it and then it [ __ ] hit
me and i was like oh my god i'm going to
vomit
durian it smells so bad no stinky tofu
oh yeah yeah durian too it smells pretty
bad i think i i
durian's not bad but stinky tofu is
pretty [ __ ] thing i don't like the
most about kimchi this might surprise
you is that it's cold
what it's refreshing do you eat
sauerkraut fried rice and it's really
good
yeah you put in fried rice oh really
it's korean coleslaw you like coleslaw i
love coleslaw yeah
it's cold but it tastes like fish though
too it does taste
eating it it tastes like fish you don't
like the fish no
oh cause it has a the shrimp brine i
guess i don't even
register how do you not wait do you eat
pickles yeah yeah that's what i register
like
yeah oh yeah it's got that too but the
after the aftertaste is very fast
they taste the fish broth and brine like
like it's
magnified i'm right here
you can say it to my face pal not just
you but i'm saying the people that could
taste it some people
they could taste some people are like
it's like some [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah i don't taste the fish at
all well cause uh
i have i think that the reason why we
don't taste it is
it's introduced into your palate at a
very early
age so it becomes normal no not me
okay never mind by the way i used to eat
sardines out of the can all the time
so who the [ __ ] knows because you know
how some people have that cilantro thing
like some people can taste that so yeah
yeah yeah maybe it's genetic
yeah i think it probably is genetic
because even for coffee like
like bitter drinkers are able to not
taste the bitterness
or like dark dark coffee that's an
acquired taste though because i used to
taste all the bitter and then i started
eating grapefruits and and black coffee
and i i did now i don't taste bitter
wow it's still bitter why should i eat
kimchi maybe i'll open my mind okay this
is why
so a team of researchers in france they
conducted a study on the dietary
preferences
of countries with low fatalities from
covid19 probiotics and what they found
is
with like for example in south in south
korea
i know it came out weird where fermented
cabbage
which is kimchi is a staple food they
found
the fatality rate of 2.14
lactobacteriasis yeah so they're saying
296 people have died out of the 13
771 people or maybe they're just
recording corona numbers more accurately
but go on
okay and then also in germany they have
sauerkraut as a staple
and they have also seen a low death rate
of 4.51
oh another country that's recording
their corona deaths accurately
so they found out 9161 deaths
out of 202 thousand
eight hundred and forty five cases yeah
so in italy spain and the uk and other
countries where fermented cabbage is not
part of the regular diet the death rate
is comparatively higher so for example
in italy it's 14.33
spain is 9.24 and the uk is 15.36
percent
so wait so they're just going like oh
they both share
that's the cabbage yeah because like
there's a lot of other differences too
there is more there's more so they're
saying that in addition like for kimchi
in addition to the high
antioxidants and vitamin c packed in
cabbage the people who wear leader hosen
are less likely to get covered like a
german thing yeah it's a german thing
okay
so they're saying that the fermentation
process creates probiotics that support
the gut
micro microbiome and uh they were also
referring to this other this other part
i ate a lot of probiotics
yeah that's why i don't got corona
oh that's funny so they were saying that
fermented cabbage
it helps reduce levels of ace2
which is an enzyme in the lungs that
covin19 uses
to gain access to the bodies of patients
so with lower amounts of ace2
it becomes more difficult for the virus
to enter the body
i could see all the korean grandmas
right now that's like see i
told you i'm smoking a cigarette stock
i toss you i love kimchi though so hell
[ __ ]
you know every culture has some type of
like
food with that's fermented in probiotics
but then what do we have
oh jalapenos no cheese western culture
is
cheese that's all but
in america we [ __ ] it up because uh you
pasteurize the milk
so you basically blast all the all those
uh things that can be a probiotic and it
becomes a sterile piece of like
boiled milk but we're killing the bad
bacteria but then you're also curing the
good what was happening in the great
depression and before why are they
cuddling us so much
they're hurting them it also lasts
longer on a shelf too that's why
yeah yeah that's basically what it is oh
if you watch the documentary
milk you'll see why milk about rv
so you know how like i get the eczema
right but when i go to the europe
i get the eczema i i can have dairy
products
every day and it doesn't [ __ ] with i
remember you were so excited and so
happy you're like oh my god i can
actually eat this
yeah dairy products all day you're
[ __ ] brave for even trying
like i if i had an allergy like that and
i got
rashes and [ __ ] i'm like i'm staying
away from it what are you talking about
you still go to the sun
yeah and you go to you go i'm going to
go to the beach well i
i actually prep for that and i take an
allergy pill afterwards
so i guess but especially on [ __ ]
vacation i'm not like hey you know what
let's live dangerously
i'm dairy only yes but ice cream's so
good
that's what i'm thinking i just spent
money for this [ __ ] i'm not [ __ ]
up yeah but for me i'm like you want to
try all the food i'll go
and see the louvre while i'm doing this
yeah i see i get it
because i'm just like it'll go away yeah
give me a week whatever
but i just wanted to taste it kind of my
attitude too when i was in
like well you're like [ __ ] i was
under the umbrella the whole time but
i'm like
[ __ ] i really want to get in the water
just for a little bit
so i did dude sun allergy is the
weirdest [ __ ] i've ever heard of
that's so strange at least we don't have
a wi-fi allergy
sucks you know what i mean that one that
one exists people
i know that's insane wi-fi allergy yeah
what about wife allergy yeah i got that
doesn't have that
sounds like he does yo you have a
husband allergy [ __ ] yeah
little husband audrey yeah guess who's
not getting a dick
oh no doesn't really work the other way
around
really really what it doesn't work that
way
you could the it's easier for girls to
threaten guys and for guys without girls
really
yeah well especially when the guy is
like i got poop on my dick let's go
examine it gross i don't get poop on my
dad
i think i pooped on my dick you got to
come see it how is that possible
it's crazy and he's like i don't know
why like she doesn't really want to [ __ ]
that much like it's so weird
well i tried to poop out of the hole in
the back and then it didn't work
it didn't hit my dick come check out
what i just blew out of my [ __ ] ear
hole
i'm like what the [ __ ] i thought you
were kinky
[Laughter]
stupid that's not
so they were saying that back in april
that there was reports
of a surge in sales of both sauerkraut
and kimchi so people somehow knew this
[ __ ]
like how the [ __ ] are you gonna know
that it was gonna help you against covet
maybe there's a lot of left there's like
a lot of documentaries and just
everything about probiotics right now if
you search for it on like netflix or on
youtube
so i think people are getting woke to
the fact about probiotics
i hope so because people are the more
that you stay inside
actually the worse your immune system
can get oh yeah and that's a scary
[ __ ] reality that nobody's even
talking about really
and the thing is um like like even with
our dairy so even with all of our um
you know like what do you call it like
our pickled things that are supposed to
have
uh probiotics in our american dishes
right like sauerkraut
pickles like pickled onions whatever
sauerkraut is not american
well it's american like we eat it on our
hot dogs and stuff
but then it's just in vinegar it's not
really fermented yeah like like it was
before it's just cheaply made
so then we have a lot of the same things
i guess brought over but it's not made
the same way
so the diet is almost super sterile
and it doesn't have um the the
probiotics that we need
to be healthy human beings do you think
the government's trying to kill us
no i think i think about money i think
they were with the food pyramid [ __ ]
yeah try to get the most bang for your
buck most profit
because you don't have to ferment if you
just put it thing put things in
and vinegar and it tastes like fermented
yeah yeah
i love vinegar me too it's my favorite
i know but the whole food industry is
like i don't think it's
really that sinister i think what
happened
is that the great depression happened
and everyone got hungry
so they had to figure out what can we do
to
feed everyone and then have these things
last on the shelf
so let's figure out how to like make
these massive farms
let's figure out how to feed everyone
and make sure america never goes hungry
and then i think that's what we're
seeing so so a lot of our food is based
off of corn and wheat and things that
have a very long shelf life
conservatives
as [ __ ] a lot of preservatives a lot of
processed food
when you go to the uh grocery store like
60
70 percent of that is like canned and
processed and saved
so it lasts months and that makes sense
and then i think that's intelligent but
also
like we're seeing the negative run yeah
it's from uh
if you want to think about it like
mentally it's from a scarcity mentality
like which is what my grandparents had
their whole lives like from the great
coming from the great depression
where they had non-stop hoarding of food
in their
garage and freezer yeah you see there's
like a lobster from the 90s there what
no it was even it was from the early 80s
it was older than my big sister wait
they did they keep it because they
thought it was still good
they kept everything everything that
they didn't eat
just in case and so it gives you that
mentality constantly you don't have
enough and so my grandpa would go to
costco
every week no matter what he's going to
costco every week just as a pattern
where is your grandfather live
no no he's not oh because i'm like [ __ ]
i bet he's freaking the [ __ ] out right
now
he would he wouldn't be able to handle
this [ __ ] yeah but yeah he
so no matter what he shopped like he had
five kids in the house even when they
all moved away because it's just habit
right well and in an emergency where do
you go usually you go back to your
parents
right but and we would have died eating
that [ __ ]
i tried to [ __ ] make remember when we
tried to open a wine bottle over there
oh yeah and i
thought old wine was good oh buddy try
to open some trail mix
jar and they're like i don't like that
don't eat that
and then when you open it little [ __ ]
gnats like fly up yeah i'm not kidding
it's like that you guys could have sold
all that [ __ ] on ebay and then a
youtuber would have bought it and be
like i'm eating some 1955 crackerjack
i'm like hey
president gerald ford like took a fart
in this trail mix jar
and like oh
[Music]